starting off this hour is Tremayne in
Silver Spring Maryland fight remain how
are you I'm fine how are you better than
I deserve what's up I have a question
first I have a goal my goal is to come
to the studio and stand in there scream
I'm debt free love it but on the way
there I have about 26,000 in cents and
I'll have about 40,000 in my retirement
plan I'm 33 years old and I wanted to
know should I use the money for my
retirement plan to pay off my debt or
should I just snowball right then
snowball it nobody know you tell people
not to use a retirement plan to pay off
debt unless it's to avoid bankruptcy or
a foreclosure and that's not what you're
facing you're just trying to get out so
what's your household income I make
about 41 thousand a year mm-hmm
okay and what kind of debt is the 26,000
so I have 14 of it is from a student
loan and 11 of it is from a car loan
good okay and so I'm guessing you're
going to be debt-free and two years or
under is that what you're thinking yeah
okay good the reason I would not tell
you to cash out the 40,000 is this when
you take money out of a retirement
account you are charged your tax rate
plus a 10% penalty okay
and so let's pretend you're in a 20
percent tax bracket and you would pay
that 20 percent plus 10 percent will be
30 percent of this in taxes and
penalties that's kind of like saying hey
Dave I want to borrow money at 30
percent interest to pay off my debt oh
yeah we wouldn't do that all right
it's a math the math is bad so let's
let's suffer through this 18 to 24
months and become debt free and I will
see you here in the studio I look
forward to it